landing and you know unfortunately one  of them has to lose right but they've  both played so well ding as well we  talked a lot about prague's play but for  ding to come back you know when his  position was  he had to find only moves about three  only moves and it's over and look at  that dingly wren his first smile so far  in the tournament and of course  pragnanda he looks uh resignated  he loses the chesapeal monsters to world  number two dingley ren on the day three  weeks before candidate starts  dingli ren  wins chessable masters he knocks out  world champion magnus carlson in the  semi-finals and he wins against the  super prodigy 16 year old pragnanda in  the most  tense final i think i've seen on the  tour  what can you say about ding's  performance david  i mean he deserves it in the end just  because his nerves were strong but yeah  i mean it could have gone either way in  the end he looks very relieved